Do you have any idea why hot flashes are worse at night? Well hot flashes are
caused from a sudden down regulation of estrogen. That's what hot flashes are. So
when you have your estrogen and a balance that it just drops, that's when you
get this hot flash. So when you have these bumps up and down of estrogen, it's a
person's going through a bit of pause or a person's on horrible blocking pill.
That's what that's what it's causing at hot flashes. I've asked both my
ecologist and either dove and he guesses it's really that's that is the
etiology of a hot flash. So I'm not sure what I'll do about the horrible
blockers because my sleep is wrecked. And as I said last week, I think it is
raising my glucose level. That can't be healthy. And also concerned about
long-term cardiac and bone health. We'll see what they say and we'll figure it out.
Yes, I do. I am very impressed with 50% reduction of your tumors. So that's
really exciting. I think they might be tapeworms. You know what they'll
treat with tapeworms where they start to come out your bottom. This is really
gross that you're supposed to grab them very carefully and slowly tongue them and
put them wrapped them around the pencil and you slowly wide them up because the
head of the tapeworm which is the last thing to come out and reproduce more and
more pieces of a tapeworm. So you love to get the head out so you have to go
very slow and wrap them around the pencil and you roll them up. Just what you
want to share. But do you know why sudden drops of estrogen occur at night? It's
probably because it has to do with your circadian rhythm of your normal estrogen.
When you're taking an estrogen blocker, you're not removing your, you know, you're
not going in and surgically removing your ovaries so that you don't have
anything creating estrogen so your ovaries are trying to kick in. Remember, your
hormones are released on both a circadian rhythm and their release on a negative
feedback loop. So a circadian rhythm is when you have this normal flow of
different times of the day where you release your hormones like for instance
thyroid, hormone is released in the morning and it tapers off during the night and
it's typically T4 and T3 that is released and mainly T490% that it's converted
and it got to T3. Same day with your estrogen and progesterone, it's released at
different times of the day depending upon your cycle even if you're not
cycling anymore. So it will still change throughout the month. It's released. When
you still have your ovaries and you're on an estrogen blocking pill, you're still
going to get some spikes of estrogen and then the estrogen blocking pill is
going to pull it out of you and it's going to drop so it really has to do it's
your rhythm. You're probably getting more of a release of estrogen at night and
it's pulled out so you're getting a spike downward or a sudden drop in estrogen
and that's what's causing your issues at night. That would be my guess.